[Music]
hey everybody welcome to hash tag news
I'm gay boy I'm sorry I'm sorry
have you heard this new theory that
there's a reverse universe that started
on the other side of the Big Bang where
time is running backwards yeah yeah
no for real oh and I'm actually just
kidding right now we have new who are
you talking to the crews right here we
have reverse Gabe coming in from this
universe who will reverse Berk hey let's
talk about all the crazy sex kids
they're having that's what CNN wants you
to think 60 seconds on the clock please
CNN released a list of sex code words
they claim teens are using their secret
text messages and you know if anyone's
in touch with the adolescent Friends of
America it's CNN no examples of the
secret codes include iwsn I want sex now
whoa hey can you take the training
wheels off your bike first and IFO to
night walk naked in front of computer
get some clothes on - freaking
twelve-year-old th OT that hoe over
there yeah that one I've actually heard
you would that shut up eight oral sex
the number eight means oral sex teachers
must be so confused
Hey Dude hang tonight want to do eight
800 what see you tonight
squeeze your two nipples no thank you
oh you firstly he sincerely apologizes
understand he didn't mean to make me
feel weird
don't worry bro still want to do eight
oh yeah now kids I don't really buy this
whole CNN list thing but you do use some
ridiculous letter combinations and
you're texting what did the Hwy a WN hey
world I'm a woman now would you use that
I don't know when their knife walking
dys nine oh two one zero Ln did you see
that nine of 200 last night what do you
even watch that reboot parents stop
trying to decipher your kids text
messages how about we release a list of
your seat
codewords huh IRS means I regret Sara
I'm sorry Sara Roth IRAs Robbie is out
of the house I requests ample sex and
401k your dog isn't really at a farm he
is dead don't like it do you know how
parents know how about instead of
snooping you try talking to your kids
like a normal good deaf decent
half-witted area and kids if you are
jonesing for fifty three X as CNN claims
you are I'm not mad I'm just
disappointed let's get outside go play
stickball with your neighbors or stay
inside enjoy some black-and-white
television or use a rotary telephone
decade are you a better one than this
one I know I'm at a time what's my
punishment I'm upping okay I mean gross
muffin and if you didn't hear people are
pretty upset this Discovery Channel show
host who said he was going to be eaten
alive by a giant anaconda wasn't
actually eaten alive by John Connor
shameless watch bait here a few of our
favorite disgruntled tweets barstool
Trent says hey discovery can I have my
own show check out the picture Oh cute
furry snake hey snap says Steve Irwin
would pass through the digestive canals
of a ball python and still be home for
dinner that night this Paul cat is a
fraud
I agree Steve Kip Steve super Mexican
says my anaconda don't want none unless
you wear a special suit to withstand the
constricted pressure and
gastrointestinal acids I could
understand how thanks for those tweets
guys they were educational and fun and
thanks for the punishment muffin you
idiots it was fantastic
actually you should have listened to
that a bag what's remember hwi aw n
that's when you'd use it oh wow Bree
let's just finish this like this video
if you think girl babe that's kind of
hot it subscribe to new media rockstars
if you want to learn more about other
reverse universes I'm girl Gabe hole
writer
ttyl
[Laughter]
[Music]